salut il ya quelques semaines le 1er
décembre pour être très précis j'ai fait
une vidéo avec un mec qui s'appelle
youtube et on avait comme délire de
faire une chanson qui vous mentalise
mais j'ai une petite frustration en fait
j'ai jamais mentaliser ce mec
sauf qu'il avait besoin d'être hébergé
ce soir sur paris donc ils stressent il
n'est pas loin de moi mais je vais
mentaliser youtube ce soir je suis un
peu stressé ce qui est bien c'est que ça
se voit pas alors j'ai eu l'idée il ya
quelques secondes je sais même pas si ça
va fonctionner ou pas c'est un test
c'est comme d'hab entraide génériques
qui sont tu peux confirmer que tu ne
sais pas ce qu'on va faire et c'est
pourquoi parce que même moi je suis pas
encore convaincu de savoir ce qu'on doit
faire mais je crois que oui c'est ça
l'histoire je viens d'arriver en fait
chez fabien j'ai préparé des petits
papiers ça ressemble à rien mais en fait
mon idée ça va être de construire un
piano avec ça dans un premier temps je
vais avoir besoin que tu que tu
choisisses le nom d'une chanson mais pas
n'importe comment
le nom de la chanson que tu as choisir
il faut que ce soit un mot de cinq
lettres hockey qui existent qu'il
n'existe pas je prends mon temps parce
que j'essaie de trouver un truc soit pas
trop commun quand même j'ai mon mot il
fait cinq lettres il fait cinq lettres
c'est un mot qui existe vraiment qu'ils
existent je vais écrire quelques petites
choses derrière ces bouts de papier
liesse et la mentalisation va commencer
néanmoins il faut vous sachiez je fais
des petits que tu là et je vais en faire
un atout de suite parce qu'on a commandé
une pizza
une pizza qui est en train d'arriver et
du coup j'ai pas envie qu'on soit coupé
en plein élan
donc je vais juste aller réceptionné la
bizarre en fait faber il est parti
chercher la pizza et il m'a laissé tout
seul avec la caméra donc
donc voilà je fais des choses qui ne
servent à rien là il ya son show qui
vient de se battre avec le chien je
coupe on a été chercher des pizzas ça
c'est bon tu peux témoigner je n'ai pas
posé de questions sur ton mot pour le
moment absolument pas alors maintenant
je vais te reposer maintenant que faire
au film savoir que j'aime bien oui je
sais que c'est pas un mot classique
ok je vais écrire plein de choses un peu
partout et après on
on en parle peut penser à la première
lettre quand même important qu'ils
pensent france c'est souvent les
concerne pas vu la première lettre
il est très lisible c'est très facile
c'est faux c'est peut-être un piège d
une consonne si nous constatons c'est
une affirmation matin d'accord que tu as
appris un truc qui au lieu de l'alphabet
ou à la fin peut-être après arrêt n1m
quoi tu vas tu as pris un thé mais vous
n'êtes que je joue très bien en jeu et
que j'ai aussi fait je sais pas quoi
écrire
il ya des trucs je sais écrire des trucs
je sais pas quoi écrire
savait pas ce qu'il avait fait un jour
avant dernier mais c'est ça qui est
offert en grèce je pense que la
préparation a l'air un petit peu un
petit peu laborieuse et là je vais
constituer maintenant avec tous ses
papiers que j'ai rempli mais c'était une
sorte de piano d'ailleurs petit conseil
musical si vous commencez à la musique
et vous cherchez un piano je suis pas du
tout sûr de celles d'asie
c'est pas très cher et vous pouvez vous
entraîner dans forte cote faudra qu elle
vraiment non j'ai non malgré un nom
lester mais là non c'est pas bien ça met
en valeur certaines de mes veines du cou
voilà ça c'est un piano on va jouer nous
avec les blanches la mentalisation il
commence à partir de maintenant
sauf si elle a commencé à partir du
début de cette vidéo voici ce qui va se
passer je vais te montrer deux notes
blanches et tu vas me dire laquelle on
supprime du bruit on supprima cadeaux
celle-ci moi donc c'est vrai que j'ai
écrit poids regardez un peu comment tu
réagis aupeo olio aéro ce genre de
choses et je déchire et font une guerre
depuis ça d'accord
donc tu m'en fais voir deux toits
également ces deux là d'accord aussi
falloir rouge se prenne sa sitcom je
suis pris une pomme au caire celle ci
écrit pomme comme j'écris très
légèrement au cran de papier parce que
je veux pas qu'ils voient par
transparence
alors je sais pas si vous voyez bien
c'est de marquer à chaque fois la
dernière tu peux changer
c'est tout ça qui est un mec de
conviction et pêche t'as vu j'avais
beaucoup d'inspiration petit jeu des
fruits au niveau de fruits s'était
produite en face de moi un fauteuil
sa sainteté sur la fin je savais plus
quoi écrire c'est de la firme les
extrêmes je prends d'extrême gauche a
mais du coup c'est mon extrême droite à
moi chaise
peut-être ces deux là ok c'est prinz l
extrême gauche mais la mienne du
couscous youtube aux faux en cinq
lettres et tu ne t'es pas supprimer toi
alors écoute maintenant il ya un choix
on joue toujours avec son piano il rase
tout les noirs et reste qu'une blanche
est ce que tu veux qu'on commence par
retourner la blanche ou est ce que tu
veux qu'on commence par retourner les
sacs noirs
on va dire les sacs noirs les messins
noir est ok j'ai besoin pour la première
fois que tu dises quels mots avaient en
tête pyrex pyrex le truc en pyrex ça
s'écrit en cinq lettres je t'ai dit
peut-être que la mentalisation elle
avait commencé avant peut-être parce que
moi derrière cette noire là il ya un
mais je vous ferai boire après bien y
vient r ya eu il ya un hic ce après
peut-être aurait préféré qu'en dotant de
la blanche la blanche c'est malgré les
choix tu as fais les choix que j'ai fait
c'est la seule de ces la seule qui est
resté coi y'avait pomme j'ai espoir
fauteuils etc
et derrière la seule blanche qui laisse
d'ailleurs pour confirmer j'avais juste
écrit pyrex pyrex comme ça direct star
qui recte comme ça et ouais mon gars
pays y r e x purex bon du coup j'avais
juste un taxi vite fait ce que j'ai
rentré agronome non là c'est ouf c'est
ouf
tu viens de me cramer en fait y
condamnaient est recommandé demain à eux
comme dalmat et x pyrex à cette résine
avons en fait c'est toujours je pensais
pas réussir aussi bien parce que le
challenge était d'anticiper le mot avant
même de commencer à écrire en faisant
croire que je l'avais pas encore fait
chaud et et après de faire les bons
choix pour avoir ça au final ça m'énerve
merci mec alors si jamais vous
connaissez pas la chaîne de youtube il
remixe des voix de youtuber connus ou
moins connus mais aussi des parodies de
clips qui sont énormes au niveau du
montage de l'écriture de tout je
surkiffe cette chaîne je suis pas le
seul je sais que squeeze surkiffe
taschen amics m pierre cros tout le
monde ça ne parle que de soi dans
youtube game alléluia donc fait en sorte
qu'il passe la barre des 20 abonnés vous
pouvez vous abonner à youtube en
cliquant sûrement par ici à moi aussi si
la vidéo vous a plu vous vous abonnez
vous l'aviez vous pouvez vous lâcher un
petit comme ça fait du plaisir et rendez
vous demain à 17h ciao
ça fait du plaisir
calao
et
[Musique]